الصحه العالميه تحذر من خطوره الوضع في
شمال غرب سوريا ومطالبات بفرق لتقييم
الكوارث
تشريع في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي يمدد
بالمسيرات الايرانيه ويطالب بانظمه
لمواجهتها
[تصفيق]
الخارجيه الامريكيه تؤكد ان سيف العدل
المقيم في ايران هو الزعيم الجديد لتنظيم
القاعده
[موسيقى]
عربه منظمه الصحه العالميه عن قلقها
البالغ بشان وضع السكان في منطقه شمال
غربي سوريا بعد الزلزال هذا وطلبه الشبكه
السوريه لحقوق الانسان طلبت بارسال فرق
لتقييم الكوارث في اسرع وقت لانقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه ومن جهتها تسابق تركيا الزمن
لاوائي منكوبي الزلزال
[موسيقى]
منظمه الصحه العالميه اعربت عن قلقها
الشديد مع شح المساعدات في شمال غرب سوريا
عقب وقوع الزلزال المدمر مشيره الى صعوبه
امكانيه الوصول الى الاشخاص المتضررين في
المناطق السوريه الواقعه تحت سيطره النظام
المنظمه اوضحت ايضا ان النظام الصحي يعاني
الهشاشه الهائله رغم توفر المساعدات
الانسانيه والطبيه الا ان ذلك ليس مستداما
من جهتها قالت الشبكه السوريه لحقوق
الانسان ان تاخر وصول المساعدات الامميه
لمتضرر الزلزال شمال غرب سوريا تسبب في
زياده عدد الضحايا مطالبه بضروره ارسال
الفرق تقييم الكوارث في اسرع وقت لانقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه وذكرت الشبكه الحقوقيه في
تقرير ان استجابه الامم المتحده لم تكن
بالشكل الذي يتناسب مع هول الزلزال في
شمال غرب سوريا حيث تركت المنظمات المدنيه
المحليه تواجه بمفردها اهوال الزلزال
ومخلفاته
معنا من ريف ادلب الصحفي محمد الاشقر اهلا
بك معنا محمد اذا مع وصول المساعدات
وازدياد وتيره الشاحنات والقافلات
المساعده
والمساعدات الامميه كذلك انقل لنا وضع
المتضررين هل بدا في تحسن هل المساعدات
بدات تغطي ربما جزء من حاجات المتضررين
نعم يعني في الحقيقه نتيجه الاعداد
المتضررين الكبيره الى حد هذه اللحظه هذه
المساعدات التي دخلت تغطي جزء من حجم
الكارثه يعني
للزلزال المدمر في الحقيقه جانبان الجانب
الاول هو عدد الضحايا الذين قتلوا تحت
الانقاض والجانب الاخر لهذه الكارثه هو
انساني هو حاله المتضررين الناجين ضحايا
هذا الزلزال طبعا للتوضيح فقط نحن الان في
معبر باب السلامه الحدودي في ريف حلب
الشمالي اتينا الى هناك كي ننقل بشكل
مباشر حركه دخول المساعدات خصوصا ان هذا
المعبر بدات دخول المساعدات الامميه منه
لاول مره منذ عام 2020 طبعا ان سمحتي لي
للحديث اكثر حول المساعدات الامميه وحركه
دخولها بالتحديد من معبر باب السلامه
حدودي دعيني ان استضيف معي
العميد قاسم القاسم مدير معبر باب السلامه
اهلا وسهلا بك سياده العميد بالبدايه معبر
باب السلامه منذ 2020 لاول مره تدخل منه
المساعدات الامميه ماذا يعني ذلك وما هو
حجم المساعدات التي دخلت حتى الان اهلا
وسهلا بكم في الحقيقه كما اسلفتم ان
المساعدات الامويه لم تدخل الا
اول البارحه ودخلت احد عشر شاحنه والبارحه
دخلت شاحنتين اي تاخروا كثيرا جدا جدا
للدخول وهذا معبر دولي من عام الخمسين
مفتوح معبر باب السلامه بالتالي والله نحن
تفاجانا من المجتمع لم نتفاجا اصلا مجتمع
الدول من اول الثوره خيزر الثوره السوريه
والزلزال يا جماعه حالي انسانيه بعد اربع
خمسه ايام سته ايام من جثث تحت الانقاض
لحديات المساعدات الدوليه تدخل عبر موافقه
المجرم هذا شيء لا يصدق ابدا ابدا من
المجتمع الدولي الحقيقي طيب ماذا يعني
الدخول المساعدات من معبر باب السلامه ما
هي اهميه معبر باب السلامه معبر باب
السلامه في المنطقه كما قلت لك معبر دولي
مفتوح من عام الخمسين انا في هذا المعبر
منذ اكثر من عشر سنوات اخدم بهذا المعبر
سابقا
وله حيويه كبيره جدا يصل منطقه محافظه حلب
من هنا اربعين كيلو متر متوسط ضمن المنطقه
جميعها الزلزال قريب علينا من جنديرس
حوالي 30 كيلو متر المنطقه اللي تضررت
بالتالي يوجد لدينا كما تشاهد للمعبر
لدينا 30 الف لاجئ موجود لدينا هنا في
المعبر منذ سته سنوات ايضا من اللي نزحوا
جدا حاليا اجوا لعند اهاليهم واقاربون
فمعبر حيوي جدا جدا ومفتوح من اول الايام
وانا كنت اتفاجا من القناه وجميع القنوات
ان المعبر مغلق والطرق لا تصل اليه ابدا
لم يغلق المعبر واستنفرت
كل الكادر المعبر وايضا الحكومه المؤقته
انشات خليه ازمه موجوده لدينا هنا في
المعبر جميع الوزراء مو موجودين لدينا
وشكلوا خليط ازمه ومفتوح لكن لم نتفاجئ لم
يدخل احد ابدا يعني المعبر من الجانب
السوري جاهز لاستقبال المساعدات ماذا عن
الجانب التركي ما هي المعلومات لديكم ايضا
الجانب التركي الجماعي فاتحين من اول نهار
اصلا لم تدخل اي مساعدات في اول يوم وثاني
يوم وثالث يوم الزلزال الا من الجانب
التركي مشكورين يوجد منظمه الاهه ادخلت
للان 43 قافله منظمه وقف الديانه ادخلت
اكثر من عشر قافلات الافات ادخلن اكثر من
30 قافله اما المساعدات الامميه لم يدخل
الا باليوم الخامس من الاخوه في كردستان
العراق الحقيقه مشكورين دخل اكثر من 25
قافله غذائيه وادوي البارحة دخل سته
سيارات اسعاف وكادر طبي الاخوه في المملكه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه مشكورين جدا
دخلوا من معبر الحمام 12 قافله واليوم ان
شاء الله ايضا معبر حمام تابع للحكومه
السوريه المؤقته في قافله قطريه من 14
شاحنه مشكورين جدا وذهب رئيس الحكومه
ورئيس الائتلاف الاستقباله من اجل ادخال
هذه المساعدات طيب الى
متى سيبقى معبر باب
[موسيقى]
من طرف السوري عبر المعابر الحدوديه هناك
معبرين معبر باب السلامه ومعبر الراعي في
ريفا حلب الشمالي سيبدا بدخول المساعدات
الامميه لمده ثلاثه اشهر وسنتابع معك هذه
المساعدات بالتاكيد شكرا لك الصحفي محمد
الاشقر من باب السلامه
في تركيا تسابق السلطات الزمن لايواء
منكوبي الزلزال بتخصيص مساحات مفتوحه لنصب
الخيام منها ملعب كره قدم بقهرمان مرعاش
والذي تحول الى مخيم للمتضررين
اصوات المشجعين الى اني نفاق دينا وفزع
مفجوعين طابور من الجائعين المتلهفين
لمعرفه مصيرهم احتضنت الخيام الجميع
باستثناء محمد واولاده سيبيتون بالعراء
اليوم بسبب نقص الخيام ما حصلنا خيمه لانه
الزلزال ضرب 10 ولايات عشر ولايات يعني
عدد ليس بالقليل كل ولايه بتطلع مليونين
نسمه مليون نسمه يعني اكبر دوله ما
بتستطيع تغطي بين مساعدات الانقاذ او
المساعدات الانسانيه والحمد لله يعني
الحكومه التركيه ما قصرت
يلهو الاطفال على امل ان ينسوا ازمه ستؤثر
عليهم مستقبلا كما يقول مختصون احمد اخرج
قريبه وزوجته من تحت الانقاض لم يلحق على
ابنهما الذي فارق الحياه يعيش في هذه
الخيمه ثلاثه عشر فردا من عائلته والله
نحن كنا نايمين انا ومرتين حسينا بزنزال
يعني بس احنا فكرنا بنومنا يعني بنام
بدا الزلزال هنا زلزل البشر والحجر قبل ان
يتركهم في العراء خارج منازلهم يسكنون
الخيام ويتلقون المساعدات من جهات محليه
ودوليه
لاجل غير معلوم عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
قهرمان مرعش
تركيا اصبحت فرق الانقاذ ترتدي ملابس
العزل الخشيه انتشار الامراض والاوبئه
سيما مع تحضيرات امميه من خطر انتشار او
بيئه او بيئه ما بعد زلزال والكوارث
في اليوم العاشر على الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب تركيا بدات تختفي عمليات البحث عن
الناجين تحت الانقاض العمليات هنا تتركز
على انتشال الجثث الموتى والمفقودين وفرق
الانقاذ بدات تاخذ شكلا ولونا جديدا ترتدي
ملابس العزل خشيه الامراض والاوبئه
وانتشارها خصوصا مع وجود اعداد كبيره من
الجثامين التي لا تزال تحت انقاذ البنايات
المدمره في انطاكيا في هاتاي واسر تبحث
عمن لديها من المفقودين والذين لم يعرف
مصيرهم حتى اللحظه
عمار الهندي انطاكيا
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
مقتل شخص واصابه ثلاث اخرين في حادث اطلاق
نار في تكساس
احييكم من جديد طرح اعضاء من الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري تشريعا في مجلس
الشيوخ يندد بالمسيرات الايرانيه ويطالب
بالتصدي لها وحمايه المدنيين في الشرق
الاوسط من مخاطرها ونص التشريع على ان
المسيرات الايرانيه ادت الى تفاقم
التهديدات ضد الاستقرار العالمي وتسببت
بالفوضى في الشرق الاوسط واشار الى ضروره
توجه اداره بايدن الى خلق حلول مبتكره
بالتعاون مع الشركاء للتصدي للمسيرات
الايرانيه وردع النظام ووكلائه وقال
السيناتور الديمقراطي بوب ان التشريع
المؤيد من الحزبين او المؤيد يعزز التزام
واشنطن بمواجهه التهديدات التي يشكلها
تطوير ايران للانظمه الجويه غير الماهوله
خاصه بعد بيعها لروسيا واستخدامها في
اوكرانيا
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
التقديرات الامريكيه تتماشى مع تقديرات
الامم المتحده بان سيف العدل العضو البارز
في تنظيم القاعده موجود في ايران وكان
تقرير اممي جديد افاد بان سيف العدل اصبح
الان زعيم تنظيم القاعده بعد مقتل ايمن
الظواهري في ضربه امريكيه العام الماضي
ورصدت الولايات المتحده مكافاه قدرها عشره
ملايين دولار لمن يدلي بمعلومات تؤدي
لاعتقال او قتل سيف العدل
فان تقييمنا توافقوا مع تقييم الامم
المتحده التقييم الذي يشير الى ان سيف
العدل مقيم في ايران وعندما تعلقوا الامر
بوجوده هناك اي ان توفر طهران ملاذا امنا
للقاعده فهذا مجرد مثال اخر على دعم ايران
الواسع النطاق للارهاب وعلى انشطاتها
المزعزعه للاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط وما
وراءه افادت مصادر مطلعه لشبكه سي ان ان
الامريكيه بان مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
اجرى عمليتي بحث جديدتين في جامعات ديلور
تتعلقان بالتحقيق في تعامل الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن مع الوثائق السريه كما
وافتش عملاء مكتب التحقيقات منزل بايدن في
ريبوث بولايه جل وير مطلع الشهر الجاري
وفقا لتاكيدات محامي الرئيس بوب باور
واوضحت مصادر مطلعه ان عمليات البحث التي
لم يكشف عنها او يكشف عنها من قبل اجريت
في الاسابيع الاخيره وبم وتعاون الفريق
القانوني للرئيس
اعلن الاليزي ان الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون ووزير الخارجيه الصيني
اتفقه على الاستمرار في المساهمه باحلال
السلام في اوكرانيا وفقا للقانون الدولي
واعرب ماكرون عن امله في ان تمارس الصين
ضغوطا على روسيا للعوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات كما بحث مكون ووان تداعيات
الحرب وتاثيرها على الامن الغذائي والقدره
على التمويل فيما دعت وزير وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه دعت الصين الى دعم الجهود
المبذوله لاقناع ايران بوضع حد لتصعيدها
النووي وحدد لتداعيته على الاستقرار
الاقليمي والدولي
وفي اول زياره لمسؤول اسرائيليين رفيع
لاوكرانيا وصل وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
ايليكوهين الى العاصمه كييف حيث يلتقي
الرئيس الاوكراني فوزينيسكي وذلك في الوقت
الذي تطالب كييف تل ابيب باعطائها منظومات
دفاع جوي ومنظومات اسقاط مسيرات لكن
الاولى تتحفظ على تلبيه هذه المطالب
بذراعه حاجتها للتنسيق مع روسيا في سوريا
اولا
قالت السفاره الروسيه لدى الولايات
المتحده ان على واشنطن محاوله اثبات انها
ليست وراء تخريب خطي انابيب لنقل الغاز من
روسيا الى غرب اوروبا وفي بيان لها اعتبرت
السفاره الروسيه انا تخريب خطين واحد
واثنين
ارهابا دوليا وياتي ذلك بعدما زعم الصحفي
الاستقصائي سيمور هرش بان خطوط انابيب
ستريم دمرت او دمرت في سبتمبر من العام
الماضي من قبل الولايات المتحده في عمليه
سريه فيما نفى البيت الابيض هذه المزاعم
واصفا مياها بالكاذبه
اعلنت اليابان انها ستراقب عن كثب النشاط
العسكري الروسي قرب مياهها الشرقيه فيما
اوضح نائب رئيس الوزراء الياباني يشيك
ايزاكي ان الجيش الروسي يكثف انشطته في
الشرق الاقصى بالقرب من بلاده من خلال
اطلاق قاذفات بشكل دوري
اعلنت شرطه ولايه عن مقتل شخص واصابه
ثلاثه اخرين في اطلاق نار داخل مركز
بالولايه وقال المتحدث باسم الشرطه غوميز
للصحفيين احد المشتبه بهم محتجز في فيما
يجري البحث عن مشتبه اخر في ظل دوافع
دوافع للحادث غير معروفه في الوقت ذاته
طلبه الشرطه من السكان تجنب الوجود في
منطقه الحادث
اعلنت السلطات نيوزلنديه ارتفاع حاصل
الضحايا اعصار نيوزيلندا الى خمسه قتله
فيما تم اجراء اكثر من عشره الاف شخص من
منازلهم بسبب الفيضانات التي خلفها
الاعصار
وحضرت السلطات سكان المناطق الشرقيه
المتضرره من مرور الاعصار من ان مزيدا من
الامطار الغزيره ستهطل في الساعات المقبله
عوده الى موضوع الزلزال فقد شهدت تركيا
حمله اعتقالات جديده وطالت اخر عمليه بهذا
الخصوص مقاول احد المباني المدمره في
قهرمان مرعش حيث جرى اعتقاله في منطقه
بوردو بودروم يذكر ان السلطات التركيه شنت
مؤخرا اعتقالات للمقاولين ورجال الاعمال
بسبب عيوب ومخالفات في المباني المنهاره
جراء الزلزال
بعد توقفها سته ايام سمح النظام السوري
بدخول قافله من 100 شاحنه تحمل الوقود
مقدمه من الاداره الذاتيه كمساعدات لحلب
بعد ان بقيت عالقه هنا في معبر التائهه
لمده اسبوع كامل ها هي هذه الشاحنات المئه
المحمله بالوقود والمخصصه للملكوبين في
مناطق حلب بالتحرك نحو مناطق النظام وبعد
ذلك بعد الوصول الى توافق بين الاداره
الذاتيه ونظام السوري تم بموجبه السماح
لهذه الشاحنات بالتحرك والدخول الى
المناطق الخاضعه للسيطره النظام وفق
المعلومات المتوفره لدينا فان نظام سيقوم
بتوزيع 60 الشاحنه منها على المتضررين في
مناطق مختلفه من حلب بينما ستتولى الاداره
الذاتيه بتوزيع اربعين شاحنه 30 شاحنه في
مخيم الشهباء الذي يضمه عشرات الالاف من
النازحين مدينه عفرين وعشر شاحنات اخرى في
حي الشيخ مقصود وبالتالي تكون الاداره
الذاتيه
النظام قد تواصلا الى تفاهم مبدئي يتيح
بحركه عبور المساعدات من معبر التائهه
الذي يفصل بين مناطق سيطره الطرفين في
مدينه منبج السوريه وينهي فصلا من فصول
اغلاق المعابر الداخليه بين الاطراف
المتصارعه على المشهد السوري من معبر
التائهه في مدينه منبج جمعه عكاش لقناتي
العربيه والحدث
التركيه انتشلت فرقه الانقاذ جثه طفله من
تحت الانقاض لكن لم يتم التعرف على هويتها
لتعد بعد ذلك من مجهول الهويه
اداه كبيره من الاطفال تحت الركام لا تزال
مفقوده ومنها ما يتم اخراجه كما حدث للتو
في هاتاي في انطاكيا من تحت انقاذ هذا
المنزل فرق لانقاذ هذه التي ترتدي العزل
ملابس العزل اخرج الطفله عمرها شهر في هذا
الكيس الاسود واستدعي كل من يقف هنا
للتعرف اليها فتحوا الكيس لكن احدا لم
يتعرف اليها بعد وبالتالي ستنتظر هذه
الطفله في هذا الكيس الاسود حتى ياتي
الشخص الذي يتعرف اليها والا ستعد
من مجهولين هويه
عمار الهندي انطاكيا
الى العناوين
الصحه العالميه تحذر من خطوره الوضع في
شمال غرب سوريا ومطالبات بفرق لتقييم
الكوارث
تشريع في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي يمدد
بالمسيرات الايرانيه ويطالب بانظمه
لمواجهتها
الخارجيه الامريكيه تؤكد ان سيف العدل
المقيم في ايران هو الزعيم الجديد للقاعده
القاكم على راس الساعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]